slash take care to get free help
this morning we are highlighting the
acts of heroism that took place during
and after the assault on the capitol
as that violent mob stormed into the
historic building
these individuals went above and beyond
to help others in restore order that day
chip reid shows us how two congressmen
put their politics aside
to defend democracy
the protesters were starting to
kick i mean hit it and do it violently
and so we were a little concerned that
they were going to be able to breach
the door the man in the blue shirt
standing shoulder to shoulder with
capitol police as a mob of trump
supporters attempt to breach the house
chamber
is u.s representative troy nails it was
just someone that maybe found some type
of a blunt object
to poke holes and break that glass you
can see
one young man i could see the anger in
his
eyes nails a newly sworn in congressman
has spent nearly 30 years in law
enforcement
including as a sheriff in texas his
instincts told him to
negotiate with the protesters i was
doing everything i could to help
try to de-escalate the situation and it
was a very tense moment
so what did you tell that guy looking
through that window
in that this is not the way we settle
our differences the value systems
whatever it may be
we should never resort to violence and i
looked him in the eye and i told him i
said
you should be ashamed of yourself what
you're doing here
this is a sacred chamber and you're
trying to obstruct
nels was among those objecting to the
counting of the electoral votes that
confirmed president-elect joe biden's
victory
but in that moment none of that mattered
i had a
a texas mask and he said you're from
texas and that you should be with us
i said listen what you're doing right
now i cannot support
i cannot agree with in any form or
fashion so you
you told him that this was un-american
uh and that you strongly disagree now
you were with the president
on the vote but that doesn't mean you
have to be with the protesters who claim
they're supporting the president
there's a big divide there right that's
exactly it the carnage from the
country's deep divide was strewn
all over the capitol building wednesday
representative andy kim from new jersey
had just finished his first vote of the
evening
when he decided to do his part it was
just breaking my heart when i got to the
rotunda
which is the room that i love the most
it really brought a tear to my eye to
see
just how desecrated it was so
congressman kim
started cleaning up the debris there was
this plaque that i came across that said
that below this plaque lies the
cornerstone
that george washington laid at the
founding of this building and it just
reminded me that this is bigger than us
this building the capital is bigger than
us our democracy is bigger than us
the most un-american of acts the
desecration of the temple of our
democracy
gave way to moments of pure patriotism
for cbs this morning chip reid
washington
what an extraordinary moment to be at
the door and
trying to talk to protesters uh rioters
i love the shot anthony where the police
officer is looking at him as he's
negotiating
talking yeah
you're supposed to be with